[Music]
bounty hunting is a complicated process
don't you agree
hey everybody is Charlie we have our
first trailer for Star Wars the
Mandalorian on Disney Plus coming later
this year so we got to break it down I
will be doing episode videos for this so
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and when it actually does start I
will do giveaways for Disney Plus
subscriptions and it will be rolling out
internationally too so if you live
outside the United States you will be
able to get Disney Plus eventually the
series is gonna be 8 episodes they're
gonna air one episode per week in the
first episode will premiere November
12th when they launched the Disney Plus
streaming service the footage in the
trailer here is just a little bit
different from the trailer that they
showed off way back at Star Wars
Celebration it's 5 years after Return of
the Jedi in the Battle of Endor there's
no central government the Empire is in
ruins they lost their power base but the
New Republic government hasn't evolved
out of the embers of the rebellion yet
so it's complete chaos is what they're
explaining so a lot of the series is
inspired by old westerns like Clint
Eastwood's man with no name so picture a
lot of these outer rim territory towns
being a lot like Tatooine like the
planet thereon looks very Tatooine like
because of all the sand but this isn't
meant to be Tatooine and obviously the
series will visit a bunch of different
planets his ship is called the razor
crest it actually reminds me a lot of
the ship from back during Clone Wars
even though Jon Favreau implied that
Boba Fett will not show up on the series
there will be a lot of Easter eggs for
everything from all the Star Wars movies
one of the ones you may have already
spotted is the gun the rifle that he's
using is actually the exact same rifle
that Boba Fett had during the Star Wars
Christmas special when the character
debuted in the Star Wars universe for
the very first time so they even have
Star Wars Christmas special Easter eggs
in this series
[Music]
the scene at the beginning of the
trailer here is the mandalorian going to
pick up a bounty that he's just learned
about that's almost too good to be true
he's being hired by Werner Herzog's
character who's the administrator of
this sort of Fringe town in the outer
territories who's hiring him to find
someone that someone is actually a
little girl that you see later in the
trailer huddling with her mother here
but he offers him a bunch of best car
and that's the special medal that
Mandalorians used to make their armor
and their weapons it's ultra rare in
ultra valuable so it's almost like he's
giving him a mountain of cash so to
speak to go pick up this little girl and
bring her back but as you can tell from
the tone of the trailer he does not seem
like a very good person you also see a
lot of Imperial stuff going on with a
lot of stormtroopers you see Giancarlo
Esposito from Breaking Bad in a Thai
pilot's uniform like he used to be
captain in the Empire and now he's just
a minor warlord because you have all
these generals that are left over the
ones that didn't die either turned into
warlords or they were killed at the
battle of jakku before the events of
Star Wars Episode seven in the rise of
the first order that's a whole lot of
the thing happening way later in the
timeline - this is happening much closer
to Return of the Jedi we aren't anywhere
near the rise of the first-order when
this is all happening the fact that he's
walking past these stormtrooper helmets
is just meant to let you know that the
Empire has fallen even though
technically there's still a lot of
systems that are loyal to the Empire's
way of thinking as you see him get into
fights with stormtroopers and you see
this giant 8080 Walker and other
Imperial weaponry and technology the way
Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni who also
helped him create the series the master
of all Star Wars television series they
said that it wasn't like the galaxy
suddenly raised their arms up in cheers
when the Empire fell there were a lot of
people that really liked the way the
Empire did things the orders that they
brought even if it was a very oppressive
order so that just lends itself to this
chaotic environment where you have
people like Werner Herzog's character
Giancarlo Esposito and a bunch of other
Imperials rising up trying to maintain
the Empire's Way of life even though
technically they aren't around anymore
Carl Weathers plays the leader of the
bounty hunters guild that Pedro Pascal's
Mandalorian character belongs to they
don't give him a name they just call him
the Mandalorian we don't know if he
actually does wind up taking his helmet
off during this series I'm sure he will
it's
point but for a little while they'll
maintain status quo for Boba Fett at
least in the original trilogy you
finally found out what Jango Fett and
then Boba Fett looked like during the
prequels but I don't know if they're
going to be referencing any of that
stuff most of this is pulling from the
original trilogy because it's happening
right after the events of those movies
Gina Carano scare achter is another
bounty hunter she's called Cara dune
she's a former shock trooper who just
never adjusted to civilian life after
the end of the Empire and the rebellions
war so now she's part of this bounty
hunters guild if you've seen any movie
with gina carano kicking ass you can
imagine what she's going to be like
during the series really cool to see
them riding dewbacks this one either
seems like it's been shot by this other
bounty hunter or just keeled over from
exhaustion
this Twi'lek is just another member of
that bounty hunters guild really nice
iconic shot of him walking across the
horizon line just like a classic western
movie the ig-88 looking droid is Taika
Waititi he's voicing that character but
they did say that his IG 11 is not a g88
it's just another bounty hunter droid of
the same make and model as ig-88 this
scene of the Mexican standoff inside
Werner Herzog's office here was in that
earlier trailer that they showed off
they didn't post that online but there's
some potato quality footage floating
around
it's from the scene when he first walks
in to Werner Herzog's office here and he
has a separate character named dr.
Pershing who walks in from another room
startles the mandalorian that sets up
the three-way Mexican standoff Werner
Herzog's character makes a joke about
how he's outnumbered four-to-one and he
says I like those odds there's a really
cool really tough standoff moment now
the really badass cantina scene I love
this takedown - he actually hooks
someone and draws them halfway into the
doorway the circular door shuts on him
cutting him in half so it's letting you
know this is gonna be a pretty hardcore
series if he's gonna be taken down
people like this love the shots of all
the bounties that he's collected and put
in carbonite Boba Fett style big
callback while Werner Herzog's
characters talking about bounty hunting
is a very dangerous profession isn't it
early predictions for the series just
based on the way these narrative tropes
play out if you've ever watched any kind
of classic Western any kind of Clint
Eastwood movie is is that he's hired to
find a bounty that bounty winds up being
a little girl he winds up sympathizing
with her in trying to protect her from
the person that hired him to take the
bounty werner herzog winds up being a
bigger villain than he lets on at the
beginning of the series what tends to
happen when you renege on a bounty that
you've been paid a ton of money for is
the person that hired you hires other
bounty hunters to go kill you and bring
in the bounty he's a member of Carl
Weathers bounty hunters guild there's
probably a bunch of other people that
he's known for a long time either maybe
done jobs with or maybe been frenemies
with who will wind up being hired to
come after him by the end of the series
I wouldn't say that there are friends or
anything like that but they do look like
they've been friendly in the past or
they've helped each other out on jobs
so everybody post your reactions in the
comments below what they also announced
that this panel is is that the Clone
Wars Season seven will be dropping in
February next year and they confirmed
that the obi-wan Star Wars series will
start shooting next year they finished
all the scripts it'll also probably be
about eight episodes they brought you in
McGregor out on stage I'm guessing it
would premiere in 2021 because it takes
about a year to turn the episodes around
most of my predictions about the time
period that the show would take place
wound up being true it'll take place
around the events of Star Wars Solo
making that darth maul post-credit scene
that much more important the timeline is
a little wonky with Star Wars rebels and
all the other animated series between
the big trilogies but there is a way
they can make Darth Maul work on that
series
ship and come to me on Dathomir and you
and i will then decide what to do but
the traitor beggars and I'll talk more
about Star Wars ob1 when we get some
more details about that series we don't
know if a soca is going to star in a
tube because that would be a really easy
slam-dunk for that series so if you
didn't see me tweeting through the
entire panel if there was a whole bunch
of Marvel stuff they confirmed miss
Marvel they confirm Moon Knight they
confirmed a she-hulk series there was a
trailer for Marvel phase four with black
widow footage with Hawkeye footage a
bunch of other stuff also doing videos
for that tomorrow they know so many huge
things today my mind was completely
blown so everybody freaked out in the
comments and why you wait for all that
stuff click here to learn how Marvel can
win spider-man back from Sony into the
MCU and click here for my video on the
Eternals teaser from comic-con thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you